[Musica]
ciao a tutti vi parlerò di invece che
come ha detto di biscotti e tecnologia
in realtà di una cosa antica perché il
mio ruolo è di cercare di coniugare
innovazione e tradizione
come si fa a una roba difficilissima non
l'ho appena fatto nella frase precedente
per cui vi parlerò di perché le macchine
da scrivere erano meglio dei primi word
processor o almeno questo è solitamente
l'esempio che si utilizza quando si
parla non di disruption il senso
generale madrid disruptive innovation le
innovazioni quelle che arrivano e
cambiano la nostra vita il nostro modo
di che fa di avere a che fare le nostre
aziende i mercati hanno già provato
provare a tradurre disruption non si
riesce ho provato con spiazzante
dirompente travolgente e vi farò vedere
tre grafici in questo discorso uno è
questo non ve lo dovete parte ci trovo
la testa diciamo queste linee o quasi
orizzontali che crescono di diversi
colori sono vari tipi di utenti da
quelli che si accontenta di poco quelli
che hanno esigenze quelli più in alto e
levate quando arriva una tecnologia un
prodotto una pratica un modo di fare
dirompente solitamente all'inizio non ha
nessun utente i primi utenti non
esistono è qualcosa di assolutamente non
funzionale a quello che serve nella
realtà
reale del giorno d'oggi e pian pianino
se l'innovazione dirompente avanza ed
era veramente
efficace finalmente raggiungono
le esigenze più più importante no
io ho parlato già di bitcoin nel 2012
anzi questa è una frase un po forte in
realtà ho fatto un telex pordenone 10
anni fa parlavo di open source open data
e bitcoin ne parlavo solo l'ultimo
minuto era una curiosità dopo fatto
rabito in valle ho fatto delle aziende
ma per un paio d'anni e anche per quella
sala in quel momento non credete che
quelli che mi hanno ascoltato dieci anni
fa abbiano comprato bitcoin subito
assolutamente no perché chi ne parlava
me lo raccontava come fosse un
giocattolo come fosse una semplice
curiosità la ciliegina sulla torta di un
discorso per cui è la domanda alla
prossima volta che accadrà una cosa
nuova una cosa dirompente che ci
cambierà completamente la vita sociale
mercato ce ne accorgeremo probabilmente
no perché anche se pensate tutte le
grosse innovazioni quelle efficaci ad
esempio l'elettricità mille case e
pensate che sia stata accolta con urla e
tripudio no sulle prime pagine dei
giornali potevate trovare delle immagini
di case distrutte incendiate del resto
la retorica era facile sei pazzo ti
metti la potenza di un fulmine dentro
casa non ha senso è una follia no
infatti la retorica di questo tipo
oppure le prime auto automobili in
inghilterra erano dei carrozzoni
puzzolenti dove tu dovevi per legge
avere altre due persone con te un
ingegnere meccanico a bordo è una
persona con una bandierina rossa che
segnalava il tuo arrivo per cui diciamo
che gli esperti solitamente non
riconoscono la prima volta che ho
parlato due anni dopo che ho parlato i
bitcoin al mio capo del centro di
ricerca lui mi ha detto un sì è
interessante e curiosa questa cosa e
biscotti ma mi sembra più che altro una
soluzione in cerca di un problema cioè
non abbiamo già le carte di credito
abbiamo l euro abbiamo già lo abbiamo
già tutto non si serve bitcoin è inutile
lascia stare
perché quando arrivano all'innovazione
sembra un giocattolo e
perché era così che era sembrato le
prime macchine da scrivere diciamo non
c'era nell'ambito della macchina
scrivere arriva questa nuova innovazione
il word processor
immaginato di nulla di quello che avete
usati adesso award processo era una
tastiera elettronica e non meccanica
ancora di bassa qualità agli
interruttori una stampante a margherita
che poteva incepparsi si andava troppo
veloce e un display piccolissimo a
cristalli liquidi che permetteva di
correggere forse una parola
quando arrivò sul mercato e dattilografi
professionisti dissero cos'è questo
giocattolo
io ho una macchina da scrivere oleata
meccanica preparata da un liutaio faccio
100.000 migliaia battute al secondo si
usa la tua sincerità pante e poi
sinceramente a me la funzione di
correggere ultima parola non serve serve
a te che sei un novizio e fai le pagine
piene di bianchetto e di errori per cui
è una cosa completamente inutile io che
sono l'esperto del settore dattilografa
da vent'anni è un giocattolo
l'altro elemento di cui vi parlerò non
ed bitcoin con tutte le sue
caratteristiche ma solo di una funzione
è abbastanza sottostimata data per
scontata che secondo me è la vera killer
application
diciamo che era più facile una volta a
risparmiare argento qua c'è un filo
d'argento per l'occasione e per
l'occasione anche perché c'è un legame
ovviamente storico nel 2016 un mio amico
particolare mi dice di farmi come regalo
di compleanno un kg di argento e lo
guardo ma perché mi regali un filo
d'argento
vale 2 bitcoin potevi regalarmi 2 bis
coin ha tra l'altro interessante perché
questo è quasi esattamente due sterline
nome sterlina vuol dire one pound una
libbra di argento di sterling e queste
sono due pound sono anche a chi
interessa alle citazioni quasi bibliche
sono 120 sicli d argento e potrei
comprarci 2 schiave e mezzo
comunque passano gli anni e cosa succede
arriva oggi il filo d'argento e sempre
qui a d'argento non costa più 400 euro
costa 650 non sono più due bitcoin e non
sono neanche più 2 sterline da più di
cento anni sono 0 0 30 2 bitcoin per cui
è perché dico che questa è una cosa che
può piacere alle bisnonne ma non alle
nonne perché le bisnonne non cantavano
ancora a differenza delle nonne se
potessi avere mille lire al mese cioè il
sogno di quelli di un cantante negli
anni 40 era di avere uno stipendio di
mezzo euro al mese per cui diciamo che
l'euro ideale non è un buon sistema lei
parla dell'euro ideale quello che
dovrebbe avere se tutto va bene 2 per
cento di perdita di valore all'anno non
va molto bene negli anni a meno che non
ti piace cantare delle canzoncine e la
bisnonna aveva facilità di fare un
risparmio bastava che non consumasse un
nuovo in più adesso diremo non comprarti
la quarta playstation
cambiano i tempi però diciamo lei rissa
che sacrificava un po di se stessa per
avere un vantaggio futuro bastava fare
questo per risparmiare
già la nonna non può più farlo deve ad
esempio investire in bot e cct il papa
non lo può più fare deve avere una
conoscenza specifica dei mercati
internazionali per applicare
correttamente il suo portfolio per
ottenere la funzione di risparmio non
per ottenere l'investimento per cui
diciamo che come nell'esempio precedente
delle macchine da scrivere che per
alcuni i primi prodotti di questa nuova
tecnologia erano sufficientemente buone
per cui ci potremmo chiedere perché è
sufficientemente buono bitcoin come
funzione di risparmio ma è appunto per
la nonna no perché non abbia più
abituata però la bisnonna sia le sue
linee erano effettivamente grammi di oro
e d argento per cui lei saprebbe farlo e
ma a una piena attenzione questo bitcoin
m'han detto che è un po di tutto è
un'azione non si perde è una cosa
complicata in effetti si è una cosa
complicata lo raccontano in maniera
diversa le diverse persone per alcuni è
una riserva di valore senza terze parti
un po come l'argento questo non è un
titolo che rappresenta argento è argento
il bitcoin non è un titolo che
rappresenta bitcoin sono grammi di
bitcoin se volete vederle i più
romantici vedranno in bitcoin la
struttura dati una biblioteca
d'alessandria
in fuga nessuno può incendiarla una
capsula del tempo quello che scrivo qui
dentro rimane nel futuro e lo troveranno
i nostri nipoti tutto tutte cose
bellissime alcuni vedono anche le
origini politiche di bitcoin l'unico
movimento anarchico con possibilità di
successo cose stranissime invece volevo
parlare della parte più noiosa
bitcoin come non come investimento
neanche come investimento investimento
una roba difficile come risparmio perché
le troppe cose non abbiamo loro digitale
abbiamo la rete di pagamento abbiamo
tutta questa block chain che non si è
capito cosa sia invece io vorrei
tornare a spingere la metafora metallica
che tra l'altro era quella utilizzata da
satoshi per far intuire ai primi anni ma
cos'è sto bitcoin se voi riuscite a fare
questo a immaginarvi una cosa del genere
un filo d'argento però con la
possibilità magica di teletrasporto
avete già capito bis coin all 80 per
cento tutto il resto potrebbe non
servire potrebbe essere qualcosa che
riguarda la tecnologia ma non riguarda
la nostra bisnonna questo il secondo
grafico che vi mostro
ci sono alcune curve
c'è una curva che sale che dice quanti
sono i bitcoin totali alcuni che hanno
spinto parla di vico ayane sentito
finiranno nel 2140 come vedete da questo
grafico finiscono molto prima fra
vent'anni between sono già finiti in
pratica tutta quella scuole scalette
invece un concetto strano che non si
spiega molto bene adesso noi parliamo di
inflazione cioè di quanto crescono i
prezzi quella e l'inflazione monetaria
cioè quanti nuovi grammi di bitcoin
all'anno vengono creati e le cose
interessante non è la linea sotto dei
bitcoin perduti cioè di quanti
all'inizio sono andati persi per sempre
come dire se io buttassi questo kg di
argento non avevo il chilo d'oro scusate
non avevo un amico così ricco e se la
buttasse in un vulcano si sarebbe
perduto per sempre ed è successo
qualcosa del genere a i bitcoin dei
primi anni era appunto un giocattolo i
giocattoli non si dà tante attenzioni
giocattoli non si mettono in sicurezza i
giocattoli quelle due linee verticali
sono interessanti la prima dice dove
siamo adesso c'è qual è l'inflazione
monetaria del bitcoin la seconda è
quella dell'oro quella più avanti e fra
quattro anni
scuserà e da li supererà la rarità
dell'oro cosa vuol dire provo a
spiegarlo con matematica semplice tutta
la storia l'umanità
l'uomo ha estratto
180mila tonnellate di oro tutto l'oro
del mondo sono 180mila tonnellate
bitcoin al massimo sono 21 milioni
togliamo 3 milioni per far comodo quei
calcoli e vengono 18 milioni di bitcoin
180mila tonnellate migliaia di
tonnellate viso 18 milioni viene fuori
che un bitcoin è raro come 10
chilogrammi d'oro per cui un po più di
un flip dc kg d'argento circa un fattore
x 10 x 20 in base all'anno ma cosa
succede da quella riga in poi perché il
bitcoin la di la produzione è
l'algoritmo lo fa di mezz'ora ogni
quattro anni per cui quando da quando
diventa raro come l'oro diventerà ogni
ogni quattro anni sempre più raro sempre
più raro
è
la cosa che vorrei fare attenzione che
spesso ad esempio i media parlano
indistintamente di risparmiatori e o di
investitori come se fossero due termini
interscambiabili purtroppo un po lo è
perché appunto se la nostra bisnonna
poteva risparmiare argento la nostra
nonna dove deve usare bot e cct
adesso è un po più difficile
se tu vuoi solo risparmiare devi farti
delle competenze per cui non è la stessa
cosa risparmio è
rifiuto a un benessere di oggi per avere
un benessere domani e l'investimento no
devo fare uno studio per capire come
allocare le risorse
quali sono i limiti del bitcoin come
risparmio
ovviamente noi non abbiamo l'abitudine
di sicurezza informatica personale li
avevamo già messe male prima di bitcoin
bisogna alza l'asticella attenzioni bit
quali sono per adesso i soldi degli
adulti solo per degli adulti
consenzienti voi siete responsabili del
vostro denaro ed ha grande
responsabilità
eccetera eccetera da grandi poteri non a
millenni di storia cos'è l'effetto
l'indie quando hanno parlato per la
prima volta tutti mi dicevano va bene ok
sto bit comincia da due anni fra due
anni non c'è più adesso devono dire ok
da 13 anni magari fratelli sani non c'è
più l'effetto l'india
la percezione di una cosa che c'è nel
passato e e proiettarla nel futuro è una
cosa che subito e non era un buon
livello ma ogni anno che passa
migliora e poi siamo nel transitorio
cioè siamo in una fase non a regime di
bitcoin non siamo fra 25 anni quando
veramente diventerà sufficientemente
noioso per essere come oro adesso ancora
un po brillante è un po ancora
montagne russe in un bruco mela
per cui non prevedere un vittoria come
risparmio a non parlo delle altre
funzioni di bitcoin a chi va già
abbastanza bene chi è quel telegrafo
cioè quel dattilografo non troppo bravo
a cui andava abbastanza bene il primo
word processor bea che gli serve subito
cioè a chi non realtà non deve
risparmiarlo ma deve mandarlo
la funzione si parla di riserva di
valore cioè quanto cambia il prezzo nel
tempo questo deve farlo in poco tempo
cioè devo mandare questo kg di argento
in cina non è importante lo mando subito
e dopo loro lo possono convertire i wan
per cui sul brevissimi tempi va bene poi
comincia andare male perché come
sappiamo è oscilla nello spazio e nel
tempo
invece chi sa a chi ha pazienza va bene
normalmente a chi abita in da più di 2 7
2 anni e mezzo ha già la sua funzione di
risparmio di valore però diciamo che per
stare larghi se tu hai una pazienza di
utilizzare la funzione di risparmio solo
dopo quattro anni cioè questo kg d'oro
non devi spenderlo fra tre giorni offre
sei mesi ma solo fra quattro anni per
cui più da bisnonna che da zio allora va
bene per cui perché per chi ha poca
pazienza perché ha molta pazienza vico
ingaggia bene sa che andava bene quando
è stato creato addirittura gente che non
gli interessava nemmeno avesse un valore
futuro lo si faceva per cercare di
creare la moneta di cesare era uno
sforzo intellettuale
l'ultimo grafico voi siete magari
abituati a vedere il primo che ha
un'estrazione del primo quello colorato
all'oscillazione di bitcoin su e giù
quello che interesserebbe magari di più
alla bisnonna invece è la linea sotto
cos'è la ii sotto è semplicemente il
prezzo medio di bitcoin su quattro anni
e quella è una linea abbastanza morbida
che sale sempre per chi ha pazienza e
non ha fretta è una linea rassicurante
quali sono i punti chiave per cui se
dovete portarvi a casa solo due cose
ricordatevi che risparmiano
nell'investimento e poi appunto che
questa cosa di richiedere a terra realtà
è aperta a tutti di avere competenze di
mercato semplicemente per ottenere la
funzione che la nostra bisnonna poteva
ottenere semplicemente non facendo nulla
è un po fastidioso è un costo sociale
per tutta la società
sei un medico bravissimo in una società
che non avesse questa cosa quel un altro
medico cometa è più bravo perché non
devi capire per cui direi che bitcoin è
amichevole per le bisnonne la domanda
finale che vi farei ovviamente un po
vincere facile ma vostra bisnonna vi
sarebbe piaciuto avervi già regalato
bitcoin quattro anni fa e poi volevo
ripetere che questo non è un consiglio
ad investire denaro ma è un consiglio ad
investire tempo
[Applauso]